[Music]
thank you thanks for being here this
morning my name is James and I'm part of
the Kotlin team at Google today I have
the pleasure of introducing a very
special guest from jetbrains who really
requires no introduction
now all of you know that Kotlin is now
one of the most loved programming
languages in the world
and at Google IO is very rare for us to
have external speakers but this person
was here last year and we invited him
back because we couldn't think of
anybody else to better to teach Kotlin
other than one of the people who
invented it so please help me welcome
the lead language designer for Kotlin
andre breslov
and vegetarians thanks for a great
introduction hello everybody I'm very
glad to see here today I'm gonna talk
about what can it be carbon I guess and
I really I'm going to do a live demo so
please bring my demo on so the reason
why I have this horrible code in the
slides is that we are all learning and
our all habits sometimes get in the way
so I'll be presenting today on the topic
of how you get out of your java habits
and get to your calling habits so we all
come from different backgrounds of
course and many of us started with the
Java programming language and built up
our knowledge of programming through
this so we remember many things and the
thing is colin has been inspired by many
languages including the java programming
language so you can reproduce many of
the java constructs and coughlin and
will work like you can get your job done
this way but it can be in many cases
improved dramatically so this particular
example is about declaring classes and
you can see here that I have a common
class on the left and the Java class on
the right and they look very similar but
this is definitely not how we write
cousin code so what are you are actually
supposed to do is like remove all the
unnecessary stuff what I could have to
say here is two properties one class
that's it right so I can try to
transform it by hand but I'll actually
want to show off a nice tool and simply
copy and paste the code from the Java
side to the common side so it will use
the Java 2 cousin converter built into
the IDE and do it for me so boom there
it is a single line that's actually all
you needed to declare one class two
properties that's it what all I have
here is a class for the primary
constructor so it has two parameters
both of them are properties that's all
he wanted to say so this is one of the
things that demonstrates how cheap
declaring classes is in common and
there is a consequence to this so look
at this code here
it's obviously not how you're supposed
to write code in any language actually I
wanted to parse a full name into first
name and the last thing and so that's
what I'm doing here but how do I pack
the result to put it out of the function
I don't have a way of returning two
things from a function I have to put
into one object and I'm abusing a list
here
just then awkwardly taking out one and
the other to make a first name and the
last name don't do this in any language
but there is kind of psychological
reason to doing this at least in our old
habits because declaring classes is
expensive right you have to create a new
file so a lot of code in it it's kind of
awkward but in college I don't have to
do this all we need to say my class full
name with first and last names as
properties and then all I need to do
here is just return that right so my
full name here it goes and now instead
of indices I can say first and last
right here so that's the idea
class is being cheap is not only saving
you like time at the Declaration site
it's saving you mental effort you can
represent your multiple return as a
class and it doesn't cost you anything
if I run this you'll see that my equals
doesn't work obviously because this
single line class and so now I'll go to
declare equals there right and then hash
code there as long as the fourth it's
over both but I really don't need to do
this in common because you probably know
that there is something called data
classes right who knows data classes
many people good so so you know that I
simply put this single keyword there and
the compiler generates many things for
me it's equals it's hash go it's to
string and many other can be empathic so
that's it
change your mind about how expensive a
class is you can use it easily in all
your abstractions so more or less done
with the
warm up let's look at something else
properties so we talked about classes
will go through properties and then go
over to functions so here is it property
done the way you shouldn't do it in
column again so the properties are you
showed you before we're kind of one
one-liners where both the getter and
setter is trivial if you want a custom
setter you definitely don't define
functions for that you have your custom
setter syntax as you probably know if
you know data classes you know that so
inside a custom center you have field to
note file but field to write to your
backing storage but that's it you don't
need to introduce extra names and
anything else so that's straightforward
right but then look at this code so here
is already a sensible logic I have two
properties one of them private and
nullable and mutable and on my first
access I'm checking if that's now and
then I compute a value and write into it
and then I output return it from I get
her so what is it it's a lazy property
right
I personally wrote dozens and dozens and
those and Java many other languages so I
got kind of bored by that and that's why
common has an obstruction mechanism
called delegation for properties so
delegated properties let you get a rate
of all the repetition of this a lazy
logic all we care about is this
expression here so let's just do it in
implement my property by just lazy of
all this
this is it so what I'm having now I'm
saying my property is not simply
initialized by something its delegated
to this lazy thing here and upon first
access this lambda will be executed and
then the rest will be stored by the
library so lazy is not a language
construct it's just a library function
you can define your own and the library
provides you with many other things so
the takeaway here is that if you have a
common kind of property like observable
for example when you need to be notified
that something was modified use a
library or write your own
so here delegates are observable does
the job from the standard library but if
you like you don't have to write code
like this when you have one property
than the other property and the other
doing the same of the same thing over
and over again all you need to do is
this actually declare a single class
that encapsulate the logic of your
property like your generic getter and
generic setter and that's it you can now
simply refer to this class in many
properties and get your business logic
database base access all kinds of
validation anything you like can be
abstracted as a library and then reused
across your project it doesn't make
sense who uses this already I know so
many people you actually should I'm sure
you can benefit from this so this is
more or less it about properties and now
let's get to functions functions are
very important right so again this is
very horrible code don't write code like
this and kosslyn please this is very
much inspired by our habits in the java
programming language when i have to put
everything into a class right so string
youto does your project has its own
string util class oh if it doesn't is
just a very new project right so so any
of my projects have them but the thing
is in cullen it's ll different you don't
have to use a class well first of all a
common classes don't have
addicts so to use these functions from
this class you have to say a string util
parenthesis which makes a new object
right I don't want a new object every
time I want it like this so I turn this
class into an object it's a little bit
of an improvement in in my insanity
right so I was creating an object every
time I wanted to call a function that's
crazy
but really in common I don't need an any
enclosing container at all because I
have top-level functions so this may
seem obvious like functions what are
they they're just declarations right but
some languages you know have them only
in classes and many people learn this
and rely on this so this is a lot more
of a cosmic way but it's so not great
and in terms of what you can achieve
with Collin because here you have two
overloads right so get first word is
supposed to parse a string find the
first space and take the first word in
your turn right but what if the safe
separator is not a space but a comma or
something so here is a more
full-featured version and then this is
how you call it actually in most
contexts right so what I wanted to
express here is just a default value in
Java we are used to using overloads for
this and also some people use nullable
parameters like pass and null here and
I'll give you a default value don't do
this in cosmic you don't need to so all
you need to do actually is simply
specify your default by default this
space here that's it all right so so
there is no need to emulate defaults
they are built into the language and
same for when you have many many default
parameters with different values like
multiple boolean's so on so forth you
can just use named parameter syntax to
express which of them you actually need
in all of them all the rest will be used
by default so this makes functions fewer
in the first place and then a lot more
expressive okay good with functions
right well actually this is kind of this
function is kind of midway between the
like the column style and the Java style
because it's actually working on strings
right there
much a good idea to put this into a
string class oh it's not because the
string class is not controlled by you we
can put everything into the string class
and you really want to keep this string
API minimal so what I would really like
to do or is something like this where I
can say my string get first word and
that's it right so it looks like a
method it's called an extension function
actually it's not sitting in string
class I didn't go into the JDK and alter
the class I can't control but so it
works like this so this is the mechanism
you can use I'll do it manually to
illustrate how we're here so I have a
receiver have type string now I don't
need this parameter anymore
and I can say this dot here and use my
this here or omit all of this on the
left-hand side so now I'll be able to
use it this way make sense I can do the
same with the property actually would be
very nice to do it this way just have
first word as a property name and you
can have an extension property of course
there will be no customization for the
separator but otherwise you're good to
go yep I'll just need to put a space
here and that's it so extension
functions extension properties it's
actually a very important idea it's not
only just convenience it allows you to
keep your classes really minimal so look
at the string class in cotton it's only
five methods if you compare that to Java
it will be screens and screens of
declarations so you can keep your API
minimal and all the utility functions
can be extensions can set in different
libraries can be modularized like this
and that's a very important tool for
designing api's do you have questions
okay I couldn't take them anyway okay
now let's all look at this here I'm
doing something very typical and
traversing a hierarchy so I have
containers and leaf elements continues
can be nested in one another leaf
elements sit there a leaf elements whole
text and I want to extract all the text
from this higher priest rate bird so my
classes are three lines of code not much
there's an element there's container
with the list of children there is add X
now I'm traversing this so I'm using
extension functions I'm using top-level
functions everything as I told you so
it's right but I don't like this code
why don't like it here to traverse a
hierarchy and your recursion right so I
need to pass the stringbuilder down the
stack and add to it as I'm going down
the tree but then I end up with a top
level function that's only needed by
this one here right so this one is not
really anywhere but inside this function
so what I'd really like to do is just
put it inside just go here and make it a
local function so it's again it's just
expressing that nobody else needs this
you don't need private helpers anymore a
look for local helpers and this can be
improved a little bit you can't actually
make use of closure so I can create my
string builder right here
and get rid of all this so I don't need
to return or take parameters here all I
need here is use whatever is declared
above and then I just do extract text of
e right here and return string builder
to string
extract text oh sorry it's an extension
function right
no sorry yeah so here has how goes like
you can turn something into a local
function and leverage closure so this
variable is declared outside my function
it's not accessible to anyone outside
the outer and I'm using here and that's
it
now local functions extension functions
to level functions default parameters
use these they will make your code nicer
now let's look at what's still there you
see gray code gray code is useless the
idea in the compiler show you that
something is not new there and it
actually isn't this gas is redundant
because we have this is check here right
so you simply can remove this and I
don't know if you see it oh yeah you do
but the text variable has gone green why
it's green it's because the compiler can
figure out the cast for you it's
actually much safer it's not only
convened I'm really annoyed with my
casts all of all over the place right so
I know it's text why don't you know well
now it knows and actually you don't need
this variable either because it's the
only usage right the same thing here and
then my container can be inline as well
so here it is I can use smart casts it
makes a quick code safer more concise
and actually it makes all the casts that
still are in your program meaningful so
when you see an as operator in khasinau
you know it means something it's not
just a useless compliment a compliment
to the is Jack above all so this thing
here it's kind of stupid because what
I'm doing I'm just applying the same
function to everything and it's a single
function so what what I want to do is
something like this it's a little bit
nicer looking and then let's look at
what we have we're traversing a
hierarchy I have my leaves I have my
containers and that's what I want to
express right I'm checking different
cases so to do that it's a lot nicer to
use a when it when statement
switchin types right here but there's an
annoying thing about it and it's again
coming from my old habits declaring at
close hierarchy I have only containers
and text right I don't have anything
else but now I have this pretty annoying
Al's case right here why because the
compiler has no idea I don't have
anything but containers of text it's
just an abstract class and I have some
cases there but you can actually express
this in common where it's sealed I can
have a seal class which means all the
subclasses are known you can declare
them outside this file and this way the
idea in that compiler know that this
else is useless so we went from like
almost two screens of code to less than
one simply applying the idioms of carbon
to this code you have questions I'm
sorry all right so now let's just
continue with this exercise and look at
some some more examples of expressions
that are written like with old habits in
mind and we'll try to transfer them
under something better so first thing
that really stands out here is VAR I
can't say never use var words are useful
mutable variables can be used for many
nice things but it's kind of discouraged
if you need a var you need a very good
reason here is no good reason
using eval definitely then here let's
look at these three it's repetition
repetition is ugly
repetition is error-prone especially if
this was not a single name but many
things change so I would like to get rid
of this repetition what I can do is say
with X does anyone remember Pascal
Pascal anyone oh good good I started in
Pascal almost so it had this wid thing
which was a building construction
calling it's a function you can use it
and here we can get rid of all the ax
things here just like this and now it
looks even more C of it right I'm just
assigning to the same variables don't do
that
okay so now have a print line with
strength plus some things drink plus
some things drink plus something it's
awkward most languages now have string
interpolation colony has that as well so
what do you actually need here is this
okay done with this one import things
into your scope with with you string
interpolation it's nice now here I'm
creating a map the old way I can kind of
make it a little nicer like this by
using my operators but it's really much
nicer if I just use a builder function
so what I can do here is replace all my
map put things with pairs
oh not pairs but pair sorry
typing when when talking is difficult
yeah so so a map can be constructed of
pairs right at Navis only said if
there's from key to Bellevue
well actually pairs are kind of
redundant in this so we're usually
usually using the two function here it's
not a built-in operator just library
function here so this is how you create
a map and when you want to traverse the
map you can say here key and value and
just have you variables like this which
makes for loops a lot more concise
well this example of code with my if
statement is something I really hated by
my code in Java because it's like these
assignments here they all fall apart so
easily I really like to do things like
this in Kotlin so if and many other
things are actually expressions this is
something pre unfamiliar for the C
language family we are used to dividing
our color into statements and
expressions write statements are things
that have effects expressions are things
that have values so you expressions two
variables and write statements to assign
things to things so Colin
is halfway between the this procedural
tradition and a functional tradition
that we have a lot more expressions than
you're used to in other languages so you
can do this here and of course you don't
have to use a bar you don't have to make
it a different line you can assign it
right away
so if expression make it nicer by the
way the result of the expression is the
last thing in the block so the same for
when when is not simply switch get case
on steroids it's largely importantly an
expression so you can also do it like
this right so not many returns here but
one return here will be a lot nicer once
you don't have to repeat yourself of
course this much and you can say even
this by the way if you want to check if
some things I don't even don't do it
like me it's only for demo purposes
don't try this at home it will hurt yeah
so this one can be further simplified
like this so again you're trying to
remove the noise when you see code like
this just try to get rid of the noise
noise is harmful for your brain last
thing just a quick demo of what you do
with null ability so these question
marks puts familiar with noble types in
common how many people I'll go really
really quick so you can have novel types
and compiler makes you do things like
this
so it's an error now string is nullable
you can do reference it you can either
do this which says just say fleed
reference me which you by the way can do
here as well right so you don't have to
write any around it and you can actually
simplify it like this another nice thing
is that you can use a an Elvis operator
like this
so - to simplify your like longer if
statements into something and this is
kind of curious because this is
definitely an expression position right
so how Elvis works Elvis takes an
expression to the left-hand side of
string asks are you annul really nicely
and then if it's a null value it's the
right hand side but the right hand side
has to be an expression right it's
basically it's supposed to be a default
so like if you are now on the left hand
side like use a default on the right
hand side but your default can be just a
richer what which means that you don't
compute any value there you'll just jump
out of the function that's a quite
interesting thing from the type system
standpoint but I'm not giving a lecture
here I'm doing a demo ok we're good with
expressions let's look at some
functional style so people very often
refer to carbon as a functional language
I don't think it is actually I think
Cullen is a multi-paradigm language that
supports functional style you don't have
to write functional in carbon but it's
often times very nice to do it so let's
have a look at this so in in my java old
days in mind i wrote this code which
just goes over a list of numbers and
picks those that are divided divided by
16 and then converts them to hex right
so so what it actually does is filter
map write map is this one and filter is
this one so what I can do even with the
hell of my ID I can do this so newer
versions of all programming languages
have something like this it can
definitely leverage this so this filter
is a function this lambda is a function
value you don't have by the way to
declare it as a variable it just get
can't get rid of it so that's a lambda
parameter colin has some nice semi semi
functional things like even you can say
anywhere in your code you can say also
you have this value also do this for me
please like prints
if this list for me and then proceed
with what you were doing like never mind
this it's just the debug output or some
side effect one to insert here side
effects are not very functional in the
one hand on the other hand this is very
handy for debugging you don't have to
break your chain apartment so it's free
so use also use let's use run and so on
so forth there was one very deep thing
about functional abstractions in non
functional languages when I do something
like this I have my repeat function
right here right so so so what it does
it takes a number of times I want to
repeat something and this something is a
function by the way you don't have to
invent your own function interface every
time just use the function types here
it's a function that takes an int every
time as a unit your end is something you
don't care about then it simply repeats
it right so when I say repeat I'm always
very much conscious about like what's
gonna cost me right so it's a function
it takes a lambda as a parameter so it's
actually just another parameter the
calling custom is to write it outside
the parentheses because it looks more
like a language construct like this but
then okay I'm running this I have to
create a lambda object right I have to
create lambda object every time I do
anything like this so there is a cost to
this abstraction it's nice code I can
reuse things I can raise level of
abstraction in my code but there is at
all on that actually in covent you can
very often get rid of the sole of
creating lambdas lambda objects for you
but just using inline functions when I
say inline my code doesn't change right
so here nothing happened at the call
site that it can see but if I say show
calling bytecode and just D compile this
into Java just to scare you a little bit
it was much yeah of an easy talk so far
so if I do this here it goes it's a
simple for loop
where did my lambda go well the compiler
simply optimized it away you don't need
a lambda right so if you if you simply
have your loop here and you inline
everything you end up with a loop that's
it so the big difference in the mindset
when you go from the java programming
language to cuddlin programming language
is that you're still use lambdas but
some of your lambdas are really free and
by the way these all are free to so many
many lambdas in the standard library are
free abstractions you don't have to pay
for calling them it's just code
generated for you so functional in
Catalan is not only convenient but also
quite cheap speaking of cheap by the way
let's look at this example so here I'm
trying to do a parallel computation well
it's a stupid sample nobody does
parallel computations and bear thread so
and so forth but I want to illustrate a
point so what i'm doing here is again
with my old habits in mind I'm creating
a hundred thousand threads a hundred
thousand threads each of which does some
work actually sleeps for one second and
just prints number and then I have to
join all these threads to my main friend
so if I run this oh it was an exception
or was that the Java laying out of
memory error basically what it's telling
me hey you cannot create a hundred
thousand threads are you crazy there
it's a hundred thousand stacks it
doesn't fit into memory just get
reasonable and that's there like OS
threads are not cheap you have to
allocate resources for threads so you
don't do such things early things with
threads but I have this example down for
coroutines
who knows about quoting Tsukasa oh good
who uses them in production
okay soon enough you all will be using
them I'm sure so I have a look here it's
very much the same code so I'll just put
a side-by-side here very much the same
code but instead of threads here I'm
creating async tasks which are using
co-routines underneath so I'm still
waiting for one second and printing and
if I run this there is no out of memory
it's bringing all the numbers and I'm
good
so again Cullen introduced coroutines as
means of making your a synchronous
computations nicer and that works but
what's the cost of that so the cost of
that is at least cheaper than having a
thread for each computation of course
nobody does that exactly but still like
or genes are very cheap you can spin off
like a hundred thousand coroutines
milling core genes and doesn't cost you
nearly as much as anything like the
battle threads let me illustrate
something or genes are really good for
right here so here is a legacy interface
or I don't know or am ordering interface
whatever so what we very often have to
do to make things a synchronous or make
things like reverse our dependencies
Lorentz force is called X right so just
ask me to do something I'll do it for
you and I'll let you know when I'm done
so here I have my mock service a request
and a callback function that's passed to
it so when the work in the comments are
done
I'm calling the callback and just
passing my answer there right so that's
that's alright it's working for for
everyone right but this is what the code
looks like when I want to exchange
messages between two services so I just
want to basically send two messages in
sequence and here's what I have to have
to do first request then a callback this
is the result of the request I printed
then next request inside that callback
and then print inside so you see the
staircase right here right
one step oh sorry one step two steps
three steps and you can actually get
quite deep down this staircase which is
not nice so what I would really love to
do is something a lot more
straightforward but so this is kind of
tolerable but what if just imagine what
if you needed to do like n coals just a
number like make a list of coals so this
is the code I came up with which isn't
nice at all so I definitely need
recursion there because I have to nest a
call back inside a call back inside a
call back right so I knew recursion this
is the shortest code I could come up
with it copies arrays don't do that it's
wasteful in terms of Mamre places full
of stuff terms of time it's quadratic
but basically you have to come up with
something like this like Nascar backs
into colics into callbacks and so you
can't just say okay repeat this five
times right so what I really want to do
to be able to do a is something like
this I just say okay send one request
wait for results send the other requests
and then if I want to repeat something
just repeat it with a for loop right so
this code here is actually using the
same callbacks only the co-routine
abstractions are distributing this away
from me so actually you can take any
callback based API you have now and turn
it into this like make it
straightforward with just a few lines of
code
I'll show you so this is calling the
same services because I have this
function right here so what I'm doing
I'm just turning the request into a
suspension function through this simple
construct it's an extension function of
my callback service I say the first
thing I say there is suspend my core
routine so I must I'm assuming I'm in a
core team I suspended right away I get
my continuation and I do my request
that's it I'm suspended I'm waiting for
a request so there it is and when the
request is done I just say resume to my
core team that's it
so this simple lines of code
turns your call back Bay's API into
coaching API and makes so it makes this
oh sorry
makes this code into this which is a lot
more readable to my sense how do you
like it
okay I see some nods in the audience
thank you yeah well actually if you want
to do to be a lot more prudent here and
I'm sure you want your you need to catch
exceptions so you know caching handling
your exceptions is very important and
that's as easy as this just catch your
exception whatever happens on the oh not
so sorry not not here of course whatever
happens with your with your request just
catch it and resume with exception so
this will propagate exceptions through
your core genes there nicely and you'll
be able to write try catch around here
life surround this with try catch I'm
sorry
whatever and catch exceptions there as
if it was sequential code but underneath
it's all asynchronous you can do HTTP
requests like this
I think IO file systems you can do
background threads everything you need
so isn't it nice and I guess the last
example I'll be showing you today is
this one it's just another show off for
how core genes can help you take a look
so what I want to do is to create an
infinite stream of numbers collects
infinite streams of numbers I eat them
for breakfast okay so I want just a
Fibonacci sequence to be generated here
and then I can take 20 of them here just
sequence of 20 I can take 200 mm I can
filter map slice whatever
so this both sequence function is a
library function and the card let's call
in standard library and it's actually
basically the same mechanism as call
teams it doesn't do any background
processing it's all in the same thread
what it does it takes all the yield
statements from here and just puts them
in a sequence so if I want to yield
something here I just do it like I
insert you into my sequence if I want to
say if TMP is greater than 10 continue I
can skip pieces of my logic so that's as
straightforward as n equal routine it
gives you a lazy sequence
okay so takeaways classes are cheap
functions our top level or local no
overloading to emulate your default
values these properties use delegated
properties use coroutines
have a nice cotton and I want to
advertise some more activities today so
if you still have questions that
couldn't take you can come over to an
office hour we're having at 12:30 you
can come over to the sandbox area see
where we're at the common booth and some
of the day at least and right after my
talk there will be a talk by Jake
Wharton about Android K DX which is very
exciting I believe it's on stage too so
welcome there thank you very much for
your attention
[Applause]
[Music]